change why Seattle udonge Alive's change
organizations guy [ __ ] the organization
also might change the world
I want to introduce you to my son
Geronimo we got this picture taken a
couple of weeks ago he's 22 weeks old
and measures 22 centimeters as you can
see there you can already identify his
cute little hands perfectly you can also
see that he's got his mother's beautiful
lips and that he's got his grandfather's
big ears this boy has got me thinking
about a lot of stuff in life he's got me
thinking about my values about what kind
of life I want to live and what kind of
life I want for him also what kind of
world I want him to live in and in
trying to answer that question I've
discovered I realized that recycling is
a simple yet powerful habit that can
help make this world a much nicer place
for him and for his generation today I
want to share with you my story with
recycling my love story with recycling
which coincidentally shares a lot of
parallels with my love story with my
wife Sophia
I met Sophie on nine years ago we
connected through a mutual friend
I liked it from the first moment I saw
her I liked to rise
I loved her smile I loved the way she
talked to me there was a lot of physical
attraction but there was also something
else some indiscernible internal force
that drew me to her at that moment I
didn't know what that force was
something similar happened to me with
recycling I'm serious in fact it was
through the same friend that I connected
with recycling he invited me to join him
on our recycling started at first I was
a passive investor we did the numbers
and they looked pretty attractive so it
was this economic material attraction
that drove me into recycling but there
was also something else to recycling
something else that had to do with the
idea of being a green entrepreneur of
contributing to the world that attracted
me to recycling so both with my wife and
with recycling there was something
external something material but there
was something internal something I could
not discern after asking Sylvia out a
couple of times she finally accepted to
date me and we started forging our
relationship
it wasn't easy it had our ups and downs
but it felt really good five years into
their relationship I started to feel
insecure that I wanted to commit further
so we broke up and I started dating
other people it was a lot of fun but on
Sundays when I found myself alone I felt
an avoid an emptiness within me here
again something simpler happened with
recycling eighteen months into the
venture the company was completely broke
we had negative equity I had to leave my
job and go manage the company and with a
lot of hard effort we managed to turn
around we had our ups and downs but it
felt really good five years managing the
company I became dad
with this clean the school clean energy
technology solar wind etc and I distance
myself from recycling again my
insecurities led me to distance myself
from recycling but every time when I
tried to do the acid test of whether
this technologies would be viable in an
emerging market context in a poor
country like Colombia where I'm from the
answer was no they required subsidies
and I felt this similar void this
restlessness that I felt on Sundays when
I found myself without Sofia after
confronting my insecurities I realized
that both recycling and Sofia were real
they were my present and they made me
feel good so I married recycling and I
married Sofia and it has been a process
of discovery after I married both of
them I discovered recently I realized
that Sofia is an incredibly generous
person the kind of person that will
gladly give you the last bite or of her
most delicious pasta plate and will do
it with a smile on her face whereas me I
get angry when somebody takes that bite
away from me with recycling I discovered
that it has silently changed the world
and it can change it again and again
over the last 20 years the United States
has doubled its recycling rate it has
been the consequence of greater
environmental awareness and also a
consequence of higher commodity prices
which have allowed recycled commodities
to become cost competitive against their
non recycled counterparts this huge
progress has had unimaginable positive
consequences the emissions avoided
through recycling are equivalent to
taking 33 million cars on the street for
one year imagine that recycling is
playing a significant role in the fight
against climate change
recycling is also a big saver of energy
there is the net energy saved every year
through recycling is equivalent to once
one month's worth of oil imports
into the US so recycling is helping the
United States become a more energy
independent country an EPA report
estimates that recycler recycling and
reuse industries generate 1.4 million
jobs so recycling is a as an important
driver of economic general of economic
prosperity so recycling has all these
great benefits it has made we have made
a lot of progress the question that pops
up next is can we do better can we
improve what's the big picture if we
look at the recycling rate in developing
countries it hovers around 10 to 20
percent so around less the United States
and it is in this countries where most
of the world's population is and where
most of the world's population growth
will happen of the next decade it is
also in this countries where most of the
growth in consumption and hence in trash
will happen if we go to Switzerland for
example we find a recycling rate of 52
percent so that's 20 percentage point
above the US but we don't need to go
that far we don't need to travel all the
way to Europe
just by looking here in our own backyard
in San Francisco we find our recycling
rate of 77 percent 7-7 so imagine all
the emissions that could be avoided all
the oil inputs that could be spared and
all the new green jobs that could be
generated if through recycling we
increase the recycling rate in those
developing countries to u.s. levels or
why not san francisco's levels so what
can we do what can we do to advance in
this path of increasing recycling rates
first if you don't recycle well start
doing so it's very easy you just need to
buy an additional trash bin which will
cost you 10 bucks and just try but just
start by throwing in one bin the
perishable goods and in the other and
bin the rest this simplified dual stream
recycling system is pretty similar to
the way San Francisco started a couple
of years ago
and it will get the task done if you
already recycle then I want to invite
you I want to urge you to talk about it
to become an evangelizer of the
recycling cost and I want to suggest
three settings where you can do this
effectively the first one friends and
family when you're invited to a dinner
check out of the recycling if they're
not they're not persuade them tell them
how it's done
and that it will only cost them ten
bucks second setting your children's
school most American schools teach
recycling very very briefly and most
American school textbooks do not cover
recycling so talk to your children's
teachers find out if they're teaching
recycling if they're not collaborate
with them so that they can include it in
the curriculum and help them getting the
right academic materials to teach it the
third setting where you can talk about
recycling very effectively is your
workplace check out if your company
already has a recycling program in place
if it doesn't you can call my company or
you can start by promoting one second
talk your when selecting vendors prefer
those that have recycling programs in
place and that usually cycled raw
materials and when talking to your
customers suggest that they use recycled
raw materials not only do they have a
great benefit for the environment but
they're also generally cheaper than non
recycled raw materials so by using
recyclables you can not only help the
world but save money so I want to invite
you to recycle to become an advisor
evangelizer of recycle I want you to
invite I want to invite you to do this
for this guy and if you don't want to do
it for this guy then good for all these
other guys
which all of you love and most of you
are likely to have recycling does not
require additional subsidies taxes it
doesn't require a drastic effort from
you it's just a small change of mansard
it's just a simple habit that can change
the world over and over again thank you